the war on sex is a comprehensive attack
on sexual education entertainment
expression healthcare and officials at
each level of government unfortunately
have a lot of discretion about how to
pursue this war America's war on sex is
a comprehensive well coordinated attack
by a large number of groups actually
local state and federal government as
well as morality groups decency groups
right-wing media right-wing think tanks
like the American Center for Law and
Justice
it's not enough for some people to say I
don't want to go to a nude beach they
say I don't want to go to a nude beach
and you shouldn't have the right to go
to a nude beach either I don't want to
get an abortion and you shouldn't have
the right to get an abortion either I
don't want to have group sex in a
commercial venue and you shouldn't have
the opportunity to do that if you want
to so the war on sex is in one sense a
war to take away the rights that people
actually have to do things to say things
to feel things that some people don't
think they should have the right to do
for example in California the Town and
Country Hotel in San Diego was going to
host a swingers convention 3000 swingers
taking over the town and Country Hotel
nobody complained the alcohol beverage
control Commission of the state of
California came in and said to the town
or Country Hotel if you host the
swingers convention we're gonna take
away your license the town of Country
hotel in San Diego said hey we're not
serving any alcohol at these events the
ABC said we don't care you have a
license that makes it our business we
don't think that you as a licensee
should be hosting an event where people
are going to be having group sex so take
your pick do you want your license or do
you want their business
well certainly America has a love hate
relationship with sexuality or if you
will a schizophrenic relationship with
sexuality there's no question that what
Americans are doing in their bedrooms is
becoming more and more radical the
sexual repertoires of Americans at home
privately without question is getting
bigger and bigger and bigger on the
other hand the government has acquired
more and more tools to regulate sexual
expression over the last thirty years I
don't think that's a coincidence I think
that people who are afraid of sexuality
they are vigorously pursuing whatever
means they can to regulate other
people's sexuality
I'm afraid that the war on sacks is
getting more intense and more
comprehensive in the area of adult
entertainment for example the federal
government has handed down a series of
indictments it's unbelievable that in
the United States there's actually
pictures and words that you can't sell
because the government decides that it's
obscene the whole concept of obscenity
is obscene
the the right to see South Park may
actually depend on the right to watch
but Buster's three so all of this
sexually oriented stuff is connected the
regulation of sexuality is the gateway
into undermining secular democracy the
regulation of sexuality is the gateway
into using morality as the criterion for
governance rather than secular pluralism